so there is no doubt that yesterday's
result represents a significant and a
material change of the circumstances in
which Scotland voted against
independence in 2014 my job now is to
act responsibly and in the interests of
all of Scotland and that is what I
intend to do the cabinet will meet
tomorrow morning to discuss our next
steps in more detail but I want to set
out know some immediate priorities
firstly we have an urgent job to do to
provide as much reassurance and
certainty as we can I spoke a short
while ago to the governor of the Bank of
England to discuss his plans to reassure
the markets and restore financial
stability starting this afternoon
ministers will be engaged in discussions
with key stakeholders particularly in
the business community to emphasize that
as of now we are still firmly in the EU
trade and business should continue as
normal and we are determined that
Scotland will continued now and in the
future to be an attractive and a stable
place to do business a resilience
committee will meet later this afternoon
to oversee these immediate actions
secondly I want to make it absolutely
clear today that I intend to take all
possible steps and explore all options
to give effect to how people in Scotland
voted in other words to secure our
continuing place in the EU and in the
single market in particular to that end
I have made clear to the Play Minister
this morning that the Scottish
Government must be fully and directly
involved in any and all decisions about
the next steps that the UK government
intends to take we'll also be seeking
direct discussions with the EU
institutions and its member states
including the earliest possible meeting
with the President of the European
Commission
I will also be communicating over this
weekend with each new member state to
make clear that Scotland has voted to
stay in the EU and I intend to discuss
all options for doing so as
see that I've also spoken this morning
with Mayor Sadiq Khan and he is clear
that he shares this objective for London
so that is clear common cause between us
the discussions that take place over the
coming days and weeks will of course be
led by government but I will seek the
support and ensure the involvement of
the Scottish Parliament at every step of
the way